well joe
tone the slab tonight in his hometown
san diego
donnie mentioned his game started his
22nd tonight's 7-7 record
three quality starts in a row for the
right-hander
swing and a miss and rojas strikes out
slider again
nice way to start the night for joe
musgrove
on the ground to third base manny
machado in plenty of time
two down and the first pitch to diaz is
hit into the man he's shift
on a couple of hops he's got it from the
outfield grass long throw to first
is perfect and in time and a one two
three first inning for joe
zach thompson on the hill his second
start this
10th start rather this season and in his
career coming off of no decision against
the mets but the second time that he
will be facing
the padres yeah 2-2 to fam
is a ground ball to the shortstop rojas
has it across the first for out number
one
double digit starts in a two and a half
era fly ball out to center for
sierra and there are two way
and machado gets into one out toward
left center field but that'll be
playable for sierra and a one two three
first inning for zach thompson
swinging a miss and he strikes him out
brian anderson
he strikes out on a slider that's the
second strikeout for joe musgrove of the
evening
sky to left field high but not deep fam
is kind of getting ready to camp
underneath of it few steps towards the
line he makes the catch
that one is into center field a base hit
for de la cruz brinson
off on the crack of the bat will head to
third and the marlins have two on with
two out in the second
the de la cruz single sets the marlins
up with men at the corners but they're
two outs now and the number eight man
magneris
sierra coming up with the pitcher on
deck 2-2
lined out toward left center field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
magneris sierra with a two-out
two-strike rbi
single and the marlins break through
first swing and a miss and thompson
strikes out to end the unit marlins get
a run take a one-nothing lead
and lines one to anderson over at third
right place to make the play for route
number one base is empty one out for
eric hosmer
high drive deep right field for hosmer
this game is tied
with his 10th home run of the year and
it's tied up one-to-one
just like that eric hosmer may have
busted a couple seams on that baseball
that he just struck
after going up a pitch up near his cap
this is a change up down at the knees
you think he squares this up oh oh
that was a no doubter
one and two aguilar awaits carratini
sets an outside target
pitch from joe was swung on and missed
strike three another slide or another
strikeout
that's four for musgrove
swung on and missed strike three
back-to-back case after the lead single
by rojas
another slider another strikeout that's
five for muskrobe two down
moscow upset and the pitch is check
swing this time he went on appeal
and three straight strikeouts for joe
musgrove after the lead single here in
the top of the third
musgrove is swinging a miss in a
fastball in he's down on strikes that's
the first
strike out of the ball game for zach
thompson two on one out
and manny machado coming up
[Applause]
base hit for machado fan being waved
around he will score
padres take a 2-1 lead manny machado
driving in the go-ahead run
raise your third machado at first two
balls and a strike to jay kronoworth
2-1 pitch and kronenworth with a fly
ball out to right center field
it'll be sierra he comes up throwing
here's frazier throw is
in time a strike from magneris sierra
in center and he cuts down a run at the
plate
chase tingler and the padres will take a
look at it fantastic job of staying
behind his throw getting
all sorts of momentum into the throw and
the throw
right online chris conroy the home plate
umpire
that is a great angle right there that
is just about what he saw
call on the field was out so the
replay officials in new york will need
enough evidence to overturn that call
here we go the headsets are off and he
is out at the plate
[Applause]
breaking ball in there for a call strike
three and myers just gives up on it
one out two one victor cartini
through the right side and a base hit
for carratini hosmer is rounding 30 will
score
crow goes into second and another rbi
single this one for the catcher
and the padres lead it 3-1 now the
infield comes about halfway in against
musgrove who squares to bunt
pulls it back swings away and lifts the
fly ball to right tila cruz is back
he'll make the catch
tangy at third is grisham the throw to
the plate he will
score 4-1 padres
on the ground right side frazier's there
that is out number one of the fifth
inning
[Applause]
joe panic pinch hitting one hopper
picked by frazier
two down correct fly ball center field
playable for grisham over to right
center
he'll make the catcher will end the
inning the marlins leave a runner
halfway through 4-1
padres musgrove is going to be five
tonight and allowed just
one pitch count is at 84.
[Applause]
fly ball off the bat of diaz to left
field as fam
back to the edge of the dirt of the
track to make the catch
here's the on one and brinson hits a
hard ground ball to short stop
cronenberg's charges nice job gloving it
through the first in time
couple of quick outs oh and two and a
breaking ball hit in the air to left
tommy pham coming in going over getting
there and making the catch down the
inning
here's louis princeton one for three
looking for his fifth
multiple hit game in his last eight
games
has he this is down the line that is a
fair ball home run lewis brinson
just kept it fair down the left field
line and the marlins pulled it within a
run
how about it sweet lou does it again
stay hot young man you are getting it
done a
no doubter to left only question was
fair or foul this is going to hit the
yellow pole
right on that warehouse one out runner
at third eric hosmer
lying to left and that's in for a base
hit
from third comes machado and the padres
have a 5-3 lead
cosmer driving in another run trey
grisham will step to the plate
lefty lefty the 1-1 pitch and grissom
lines it the other way that will get
down a fair ball it's going to roll all
the way to the corner
hosmer is on his way into score meyers
racing behind him he will score
grisham's heading for third the slide
he's in with a two-run triple
and a 7-3 padre lead in the eighth
strike three padres win
striking on the side is austin adams as
the padres
taking one of this three-game series
against the marlins